[موسيقى]
ما وراء الافلام مع محمود النجار على
العربيه بودكاست في 2009 كان اول ظهور
وبعدها ب 14 سنه بنشوف الجزء التاني منه
وبنعيش معه متعه بصريه مستحيل تنساها
اهلا بك في حلقه جديده من بودكا الافلام
المقدم من العربيه انا محمود النجار
والنهارده هاخدك في رحله لبندوره المكان
الاجمل على الاطلاق كل مره بحكي لك عن
حاجه حصلت قبل كده بس لاحكي لك عنه
النهارده هيكون في المستقبل وبالتحديد سنه
2154 وكان يا مكان وفي الوقت ده ارضنا
العزيزه استفزت كل مواردها الطبيعيه وقتها
بيحصل الحل المعتاد نبعت لمكان تاني يكون
في موارد افضل نقدر نستغلها ونعيش بيها ده
الحل المعروف للبشريه من قديم الازل وبيقع
الاختيار فعلا على
بندوره عباره عن قمر في نظام النجوم لالفا
سيناتوري واللي بالمناسبه مكان مناسب
لوجود البشر عليه كل سكان بندوره بيطلق
عليهم اسم
وهم عباره عن كائنات طولها 10 قدم اللي هو
3 متر لهم بشره زرقاء باجسام رشيقه جدا
وبيعيشوا في تناغم وسلام مع الطبيعه من
لحظه ما قلت لك ان البشر ما يقدروش يعيشوا
على بندوره علشان كده العلماء بيلجاوا
الابتكار الافاتورز
عباره عن اشكال هجينه من النافاي يعني هم
شبه السكان الاصليين بس معروف انهم مش من
السكان وبتبدا احداث القصه في الجزء الاول
من لما بيوصل جيك سالي وافتكر الاسم ده
كويس علشان هيفضل عايش معنا كتير
هو جندي مشلول بيتم ارساله البندوره علشان
يحل محل اخوه المتوفي وهنا خليني احكي لك
ان لكل افاتار مستخدم
بس بسبب وفاه اخوه قرر المسؤولين ان جيك
هيحل مكانه لان لهم نفس الجينات الوراثيه
فبالتالي جاك هيقدر يتحكم في اوتار اخوه
الفيلم بيبدا بحلم بنجيك وبيقول انه دايما
شايف نفسه بيجري في الطبيعه وبعدها بنشوف
هو بيصحى من ثبات عميق وبنبدا نتعرف على
شخصيات الفيلم فمثلا الدكتوره جريس
اوغستين هي المسؤوله عن الافاترات وفي نفس
الوقت هي الشخص الوحيد المسالم بالنسبه
للسكان الاصليين
هترفض تماما وجود شيك لدرجه انها هتعترض
على ده بشكل واضح خاصه ان جيك مش عالم
وهتقول ان اخر حاجه هتحتاجها في فريقها
واحد بيرمي رصاص على كل اللي حواليه لكنها
ما كانتش تعرف ان جيك هو اللي هيغير
مصيرهم
في اول رحله من رحلات جيك مع دكتور جريس
وصديقه نورم بيتعرض شيك لهجوم من كائنات
في بندوره ولما بيهرب جيك للغابه بتكون
بتراقبه
وبتضطر تحميل للسبب هتعرفه قدام
بتنقذه وهتاخده لعشيرتها وقتها ابوها
الزعيم انها تساعد جيك يدمج وسط مجتمعهم
وتعلموا لغتهم وبالفعل هتبدا رحله جيك جوه
بندوره بكل تفاصيلها العظيمه لكن للاسف
لازم شرير القصه اللي بيدمر حياه البطل
وهنا كان دور الكولونيل مايلز رئيس قوه
الامن مايلز انه هيساعده يتحرك تاني لو
قدم له معلومات مفيده عن اماكن تجمعهم ايه
الاماكن المقدسه عندهم ايه اسرارهم والاهم
من ده كله الشجر الام ودي شجره عملاقه جدا
بيقدسها اهل بندوره لانها مرتبطه عندهم
بكل جزء من الطبيعه الكولونيل مايلز كان
بيستهدف الشجره دي لان تحتها رواسب غنيه
من الاونوب ودي الماده اللي بيسعى عليها
البشريين بيتعلم بسرعه جدا وبيندمج في وسط
وبيتعلم لغتهم وتقاليدهم وبيقرب لهم فعلا
وبيحب وبيتعرف على القبيله لكن مش هتكون
دي المشكله الاكبر المشكله الحقيقيه في
الجيش اللي عايز يدمر فندورا وبسبب
معلومات جيك هيقدروا يعملوا ده فعلا ولما
جايك بيعترض طريقهم بيقولوا له قدامك ساعه
واحده بس تقنعهم يخلوا المكان بيعترف لاهل
بندوره انه كان جاسوس وبيتاخد اسير هو
ودكتور جريس ولكن للاسف الجيش بيدمر
الشجره المقدسه وهيتعرض عدد كبير من الشعب
للتدمير منهم الزعيم والد نيتشري في الوقت
ده الاحداث بتشدك جدا شيك وجريس في قبضه
اهل بندوره واهل بندوره مش مقتنعين ولا
موافقين بتصرفات البشر وكمان بيتعرضوا
لتهديد كبير جدا وقتها هيبدا يظهر شخصيات
مساعده لجيك زي
علشان ما يتعرضوش للاكل ولكن للاسف دكتور
جريس بتتعرض للهجوم وبتتصب فعلا جيك هيكون
موقفه سيء خسر ثقه السكان وجريس مصابه وما
فيش معهم اسلحه كفايه يواجهوا بها الخطر
ده وقتها هيقرر انه لازم يرجع ثقه
وعلشان يعمل ده بيحقق اسطوره من اساطرهم
وهي انه يبقى مالك التورك
مخلوق شبه التنين بيخاف منه اهل النافاين
وفي نفس الوقت بيقدسوه بعد ما جيت بيستعاد
ثقتهم بيحاول ينقذ دكتور جريس لكن للاسف
بيفشل وبعدها بتبدا الحرب الاكبر بعد
ماجيك قدر يوحد القبائل ويقنعهم ان عدوهم
واحد وبالفعل بتبدا الحرب مين اللي فاز
فيها الطبيعه ولا التكنولوجيا الايمان ولا
العنف ده اللي هتعرفه الجزء الاول من فيلم
افاتار ورا افاتار مبدعين كتير منهم
المخرج العب
وفي نفس الوقت هو اللي كتب الفيلم واشتغل
على تطويره قدم الممثل
سنه 2009
سنه 2009 اول ما الفيلم نزل تلقى مراجعات
ايجابيه جدا خاصه بسبب الاثاره البصريه
لانك حرفيا بتعيش جوه بندوره من شده
التفاصيل المميزه اللي ظاهره في التصوير
والمونتاج بس ايه اللي حصل بعدها وليه 14
سنه علشان يظهر افاتار لنور تاني ايه
القصه اصلا خليني اقول لك ان ظهور افاتار
التاني كان افاتار اللي كان بيحصل فيه
هجوم على بندوره تاني من البشر بس المره
دي البشر اقوى ومعهم اسلحه ذكيه اكتر
وقائد مؤذي اكتر والمره دي مش حرب علشان
الموارد لا
حرب انتقام ورد اعتبار في الجزء تاني من
افاتار بيكون جيك سالي مبيتشري عائلتهم
كبرت وبقى عندهم اطفال ومع رجوع البشر او
اهل السماء زي ما بيسموهم اهل فندوره
بيكون جيك وعيلته في خطر كبير وهنا بتبدا
رحلتهم علشان يلاقوا بيت تاني يقدروا
يعيشوا فيه ويتعايشوا فيه الفيلم نزل في
اخر عشرين 2022 ولو دخلت السينما هتشوفه
هتعيش تجربه مستحيل تنساها في النهايه
عايز اشاركم اهم حاجتين هتتعلمهم من
الافاتار وهتشوفهم بشكل ملحوظ جدا واحد
تكريم المقدس الموضوع الرئيسي للفيلم هو
الطريقه
وانها دايما هتنقذهم اتنين الجماعه دايما
اهم اكتر حاجه بتميز اهل النافعه الطريقه
اللي بيعيشوا بيها بتعاون واخاء فمثلا في
الجزء التاني لما جه صلي واسرته راح لاهل
الماء يستنجد بهم علشان يعيشوا هناك رحبوا
بيه على الرغم انهم عارفين مخاطر ده وانهم
ممكن يموتوا بسبب حماي الاسره دي وفي
الفيلم الاول اللي انقذهم كان تعاونهم سوا
حتى لو الحرب مش حربهم لازم يحموا بعض
الفيلم مليان دروس كتير ومتعه اكتر
وتفاصيل هتعيشها مع كل مشهد الجزء الاول
عبقري والجزء التاني اكثر عبقريه شوف
الجزئين دلوقتي واستمتع بهم واستناني
الحلقه الجايه بفيلم جديد في بودكاست ما
وراء الافلام المقدمه للعربيه
[موسيقى]